let me call your attention to a great
power which is greater than poverty
greater than the lack of Education
greater than all of your fears and
superstitions combined it is the power
to take possession of your own mind and
direct it to whatever ends you may
desire and it must have been considered
the greatest of all of his gifts to man
because it is the only thing over which
man has the complete and unchallengeable
right of control and Direction you are
simply directing your mind the power to
attract these undesirable circumstances
because it is true that whatever your
mind feeds upon your mind attracts to
you now you see why it is important that
you recognize that all success begins
with definite as a purpose with a clear
picture in your mind of precisely what
you want from Life hey it's Evan
Carmichael and I make these videos
because when I started my first business
I really struggled to believe myself I
was making 300 bucks a month and quit on
my business partner and the thing that
saved me was watching the stories of
successful entrepreneurs they gave me
strategies as well well as hope and
belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's learn how you can
manifest faster enjoy
then Mr Carnegie continued his speech
with a description of a great universal
truth which made such an impact upon my
mind as I began being there to give
myself a new outlook on life and I set
up for myself they go so far above my
previous achievements that it shocked my
friends and relatives when they heard
about it
everyone said Mr Carney it comes to the
Earth plane blessed with the privilege
of controlling his mind power and
directing it to whatever ends he may
choose but he continued everyone brings
over with him at Birth the equivalent of
two sealed envelopes one of which is
clearly labeled the riches you may enjoy
if you take possession of your own mind
and direct it to ends of your own choice
and the other is labeled the penalties
you must pay if you neglect to take
possession of your mind and direct it
and now let me reveal to you said Mr
Carnegie the contents of those two
sealed envelopes
in the one labeled riches
is uh this list of blessings
one Sound Health
two Peace of Mind three a labor of love
of your own choice four
Freedom From Fear and worry
five a positive mental attitude
six material which is of your own choice
and quantity in the field envelope
labels penalties Mr Carnegie continued
is this list of the prices one must pay
for neglecting to take possession of his
own mind
one ill health two fear and worry three
indecision and doubt for frustration and
discouragement throughout life five
poverty unwant six and a whole flock of
evils consisting of Envy greed the
jealousy anger hatred and Superstition
now on my mission in life is to help you
and everyone who needs my help
to open up and use the contents of the
sealed envelope labeled riches and the
starting point from which you must take
off if you wish to write your own ticket
from here on out for the remainder of
your life
I will describe for you in these simple
instructions one
procure in each pocket size
a notebook or something on the order of
this one here loose leaf affair
and on page one write down a clear
description of your major desire in life
the one circumstance or a position or
thing which you will be willing to
accept as your idea of success
and remember before you begin writing
that your all my limitations are those
which you set up in your own mind or
permit others to set up for you
two on page two of your notebook write
down a clear statement of precisely what
you intend to give in return for that
which you desire from life and then
start in right where you stand now to
begin giving and three
memorize both of your statements what
you desire and what you intend to give
in return for it and repeat them at
least in 10 times daily and always end
your statements with this expression of
gratitude for the blessings with which
you were gifted at Birth I ask not for
Divine Providence for more riches
but more wisdom will wish to accept and
use wisely the riches I received at
Birth in the form of the power to
control and direct my mind to whatever
anxieties are rule number two is change
your thinking with Louise Hay you say
that if we change our thinking we can
change our lives oh we do we do
constantly all the time you think a
negative thought you're going to go on a
downward spiral you think a positive
thought you'll attract wonderful things
to you absolutely literally so
can you share with us a little bit more
about your beliefs and ideas and
thoughts about ourselves and the cause
of our physical and emotional problems
well I've come to realize it boils down
to choosing the thoughts you think and
choosing the foods you eat and when you
can be wise in both areas you have
perfect health because the body knows
how to take care of itself but not if
you give it a lot of junk
and not if you give yourself a lot of
junk thoughts so it's it's a clearing
it's clearing the weeds from the area
from the mind and from the soil and well
I couldn't agree with you more no I've
been I've been following your work for
years and years and so but for those of
people that have tried to change their
thinking but seem to be stuck and can
you give them some advice to help them
to be more positive or to get through
well I don't think that they've been
trying and they're stuck I think they
just haven't tried because if you will
practice this even a small amount it
makes a difference I have a simple
exercise I give everybody and some
people say oh that's so stupid it's so
silly but I asked them to look in the
mirror especially first thing in the
morning and just look in their eyes and
say their name and say I love you I
really really love you and this is
enormously hard for most people to do to
begin with but as you continue to do it
it makes a big difference you see life
loves you life really loves you but if
you don't love yourself it's very hard
for life to bring you the goodies
because you've got this wall up so when
you can learn to love who you are and
that's the way you were born when you
were a little tiny baby and when I say
you I mean everybody listening to this
we all adored ourselves we loved our
bodies we loved every part of ourselves
and then we started to listen to other
people who told us we weren't good
enough or we didn't do it right or no no
no and so we've decided that maybe we
weren't very good
and that's where we get all mixed up but
when we can get back to that point of
just adoring this marvelous Critter in
here uh then life says oh she's got it
she's got it let's give her goodies and
then the next step is to be very
grateful about it yes when you're really
grateful then they want to give you more
rule number three is become more of who
you are with Michael Bernard Beckwith
first level is the level of when people
manifest
basically what they're seeking to
manifest is something that has been
given to them by Society by their
parents something that's become popular
in the world and they use the sacred
laws of manifestation to get the things
that they want and oftentimes later on
discover that
it wasn't really true manifestation it
wasn't really something born out of the
calling of their soul it was just
something that was popular in the moment
and they received it and they were
temporarily happy only to discover that
a few weeks later the the intrinsic Joy
was not really activated many people
operate at that level then there's what
is called true manifestation true
manifestation is when you're bringing
something into expression but along with
it you're cultivating your soul you're
becoming more yourself so at the end of
the manifestation if it's a true
manifestation not only have you brought
something into the visible World which
you've also changed you've also
transformed true manifestation is akin
to what I call the law of Radiance which
is you're not trying to attract
something to yourself you're seeking to
have the frequency and the vibration
that you already have it and then you
radiate to that frequency and in that
frequency that vibrate Nation then
condenses itself into your needs may it
condenses itself into open opportunities
beautiful opportunities it condenses
itself into possibilities it condenses
itself into new things coming into your
life but not without you becoming more
you
and so over the number of years many
people have been operating under the Old
Law of manifesting which is to imagine
something and let your mind embrace it
and this is to get what you want
it's old it's outdated it's entry level
at its best
true manifestation says that what I want
I have it
and I do not want anything
that doesn't come with the emergence of
more me more of my authentic self
do you realize that when a farmer plants
a seed there's no cause and effect
relationship it's not making that thing
happen
seed is planted in fertile soil and that
which is already within the seed emerges
we live in a field of infinite potential
we are infinite beings so what's really
happening with true manifestation
something is emerging that's already
there and then you'll understand
something else
you'll understand Bliss many people
never get to Bliss they hang out in
temporary happiness a temporary
counterfeit happiness based on a
temporary circumstance Bliss comes from
the activation of your potential in true
manifestation your potential is
activated and you find yourself in
Greater states of bliss and Ecstasy of
which most people never have a chance to
even embody because they're caught up in
circumstance also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is believe with Ernest
Holmes the great teacher the great
metaphysician the great way Shore
he said when you pray
believe that you already have what
you're asking for
you know Jesus didn't say uh
God all this power will be displeased if
you
for a loaf of bread and as a matter of
fact he fed the multitude
he did not say God of his power doesn't
wish you to have any uh enjoyment in
life
he spoke of a joy which would complete
ours he said it is done unto you
but as you believe
therefore he said when you pray
believe that you have
just believe that you have is it so hard
to believe that we have
we believe that tomorrow will come
we believe that the sun will rise in the
morning and set at night
we believe that the ocean and the tide
will be there and the Moon
we believe the grass will grow
We Believe
that our food will digest
and who is there who knows
how any of these things happen
did you ever stop to think
that the United intelligence of the
human race
all the scientists living
all the philosophers
all the theologians everybody
put together
does not know how it is
that a hen
can lay an egg
not does it know how it is that a
chicken can come out of an egg
that amazing
all we know is we set the hand
and the chicken does come out of the egg
this is the Mystery of Life
this is the mystery of faith
the power greater than we are
Jesus did not say
what is your particular religion
spoke to every man
in his own language
just believe
and it will be done unto you
it seems too good to be true doesn't it
and you and I will never know
until we try it as we're going to at the
end of this short Discord
we're actually going to use this power
you and I
for a definite purpose I'm going to use
it
for a definite purpose you are will
watch and see but let us be sure
that we believe just as we believe
our food will Digest
just as we know the sun's going to rise
in the morning
just as We Know
that the world is still around
that you and I do not know
how it is we can eat ham sandwiches
drink milk
tea or coffee
and have it turn into flesh
you know and blood than marrow
everywhere we looked
we are watching The Mystery of Life
the riddle of life
someone has said and I think rightly
that the riddle of life is understood
[Music]
by him who knows that God is good
who makes a ladder of his faith
and climbs from sense to Soul
finds no mind between their human
goodness
and divine
but judging God by what in man is best
with a child's Trust
leans on a Father's breath
it isn't so hard to believe
we just haven't thought how easy it is
to believe and you know
it will just take it that way and we'll
say
yes the world is round
I am held in place by some power rule
number five is use the power of your
imagination with Neville Goddard the
purpose of this record
is to show you how to use your
imagination to achieve your every desire
most men are totally unaware of the
creative power of imagination
and invariably bow before the dictates
of facts and accepts life on the basis
of the world without
but when you discover this creative
power within yourself
you will boldly assert the supremacy of
imagination and put all things in
subjection to it
when the man speaks
of God in man is totally unaware that
this power called God in man is man's
imagination
this is the creative power amen
there is nothing under Heaven that is
not plastic as Potter's clay to the
touch of the shaping Spirit of
imagination
once a man say to me you know Neville I
love to listen to you talk about
imagination
but as I do so I invariably touch the
chair with my fingers and push my feet
into the rug just to keep my sense of
the reality and the profundity of things
well undoubtedly he is still touching
the chair with his fingers and pushing
his feet into the rub but now let me
tell you another one who didn't touch
with her fingers and didn't push that
foot of hers unto the board of the
streetcar
it's the story of a young girl just
turned 17. it was Christmas Eve
and she is sad of heart
for that year she had lost her father in
an accident and she's returning home to
what seemed to be an empty house
she was untrained to do anything so got
herself a job as a waitress
this night is quite late Christmas Eve
it's raining the car is full of laughing
boys and girls home for their Christmas
Vacation
and she couldn't
heal the tears
they said it was raining
tuck her face into the heavens to mingle
her tears with rain
and then holding the rail of the
streetcar
this is what she did
he said this is not rain
or this is prey from the ocean
and this is not the salt of tears that I
taste but this is the salt of the sea in
the Wind
and this is not San Diego
this is a ship and I'm coming into the
Bay of Samoa
and there she felt the reality of all
that she had imagined
then came the end of the journey
and all are out
ten days later this girl received the
letter from a firm in Chicago saying
that her Aunt several years before when
she sailed for Europe
deposited with them three thousand
dollars with instructions if she did not
return to America
this money should be paid to her niece
they had just received information of
the ants death and we're now acting upon
her instructions
one month later this girl's sailed for
Samoa
as she came into the bay it
and there was salt of the sea in the
wind it wasn't raining but there was
spraying in the air and she actually
felt what she felt one month before only
this time she had realized her objective
now this whole record is technique I
want to show you today how to put your
wonderful imagination right into the
feeling of your wish fulfilled and let
it remain there and fall asleep in that
state and I promise you from my own
experience you will realize the state in
which you sleep if you could actually
feel yourself right into the situation
of your fulfilled desire and continue
therein until you fall asleep
as you feel yourself right into it
remain in it until you give it all the
tones of reality until you give it all
the sensory viviness of reality as you
do it in that state quietly fall into
sleep
and in a way you will never know you
could never consciously devise the means
that will be employed you will find
yourself moving across a series of
events leading you towards the objective
realization of this state
now here is a practical technique the
first thing you do you must know exactly
what you want in this world
when you know exactly what you want
as lifelike like a represent
[Music]
and what you would touch and what you
would do I'm physically moving in such a
state
for example suppose I wanted a home but
I had no money
but I still know what I want
I without taking anything into
consideration I would make as life like
a representation of the home that I
would like with all the things in it
that I would want and then
this night as I would go to bed
I would in a state a drowsy sleepy State
the state that borders upon sleep I
would imagine that I am actually in such
a house that would I just step off the
bed I would step upon the floor of that
house will I to leave this room I would
enter the room that is adjacent to my
imagined room in that house
and while I am touching the furniture
and feeling it to be solidly real and
while I am moving from one room to the
other in my imaginary house I will go
sound asleep in that state
and I know that in a way I could not
consciously devise I would realize my
house I have seen it work time and time
again
if I wanted promotion in my business I
would ask myself what additional
responsibilities would be mine would I
to be given this great promotion what
would I do what would I say what would I
see how would I act and then in my
imagination I will begin to see and
touch and do and act as I would utterly
see and touch and act were I in that
position
if I now desired the mate of my life or
I now in search of some wonderful girl
or some wonderful man
what would I actually find myself doing
that would imply that I have found my
state
for instance suppose now I was a lady
one thing I would definitely do I would
wear a wedding ring
I would take my imaginary hands and I
would feel the ring that I would imagine
to be there and I would keep on feeling
it and feeling it until it seemed to me
to be solidly real I would give it all
the sensory vividness I am capable of
giving anything and while I am feeling
my imaginary ring which implies I am
married I would sleep
this story has told us in the song of
songs or the Song of Solomon it is said
at night on my bed
I sought him whom my soul loveth I found
him whom my soul loveth and I would not
let him go until I brought him into my
mother's house right into the Chamber of
her that conceived me if I would take
that beautiful poem and put it into
Modern English into practical language
it would be this
while sitting in my chair
I would feel myself right into the
situation of my fulfilled desire
and having felt myself into that state I
would not let it go I will keep that
mood alive and in that mood I would
sleep that is take it right into my
mother's chamber into the Chamber of her
that conceived me you know people are
totally unaware of this fantastic power
of the imagination but when when begins
to discover this power within it he
never plays the part that he formally
played he doesn't turn back and become
just the reflective life from here on in
he is the affected of life
The Secret of it is to Center your
imagination in the feeling of the wish
fulfilled and remain bearing for in our
capacity to live in the feeling of the
wish fulfilled lies our capacity to live
the more Abundant Life and rule number
six the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is use the power of
five with Jack Canfield you know there's
a well-known Chinese proverb that says a
journey of a Thousand Miles begins with
a single step
far too often though people get caught
up in wanting immediate huge results and
tend to underestimate the importance and
impact of taking small steps
consistently over time over long term
time toward achieving their goals in
life but the problem with focusing on
immediate results is they usually either
don't happen or they require a large
amount of personal sacrifice or
investment to to achieve them and a lot
of people when faced with that kind of
obligation will get scared and decide is
not worth it so they end up not making
any real attempt at all which is tragic
because if they had only started with
taking small steps and consistently
nudging themselves toward their goals
chances are they would have cultivated
the skills the experience and the
momentum that they needed to actually
achieve their dreams on a slightly
longer time frame and that's the thing
about taking small steps when you do it
consistently they can add up in a big
way
tiny leaps are capable of resulting in
huge changes over time so instead of
feeling like you have to go big and bold
all the time toward your dreams I
encourage you instead to think of your
success Journey as a series of small
shifts and when working toward a goal
whatever that goal might be taking small
but consistent actions every day is
almost always the best way to get there
if you're ready to make the first tiny
step on the path to Major results here's
how to get started
now there's a simple tool that you can
use to ensure that you're taking
consistent positive steps toward the
goal called the rule of five and the
rule of five states that every day you
should do five things that will move you
closer to achieving your goal it doesn't
matter how small these things are so
long as they're action oriented steps
that will actually nudge you forward to
your desired result
so if you're running a business do five
specific things each day that will grow
or otherwise improve your business in
some way if you're hoping for a
promotion of work do five things each
day that will make your promotion more
likely whatever your goal may be taking
five steps toward reaching it each day
and every day will yield major progress
often even faster than you think
for example writing a book may seem like
a Monumental task
however what if you committed to writing
just 500 Words a day 500 Words equals
about one page so by the end of the year
you'd have written a book that is 365
pages long and by simply committing to
making small progress each day you will
have turned what otherwise may seem like
an insurmountable Challenge and is
something you can accomplish in a year's
time or less
the same goes for goals that may be less
intimidating you're writing a book that
are beneficial all the same for example
if you want to start reading more simply
commit to reading two pages a day and by
the end of the year you'll have read
over 700 pages
if you want to cut back on calories
simply cut out one Coke a day and by the
end of year you will have consumed 43
000 fewer calories
so whatever your goals are if you commit
to small Daily Progress chances are
you're going to be astounded by the
results
another thing you can do is to link new
behaviors you want to adopt to the
things you already do
see the human mind is great at
developing associations between Concepts
and tests and this is a principle that
you can use to make small steps that
might be difficult at first to more
easily integrate them into your into
your daily routine
and when you link things that you don't
necessarily want to do or that are
uncomfortable to do with things that you
have to do making continual progress
becomes much easier for example if
you're wanting to start working out more
what about doing three push-ups after
each time you go to the bathroom during
the day now going to the bathroom is
something you're not going to be able to
avoid or brush off
and most people go about 10 times a day
so this means that if you do three
push-ups each time you come out of the
bathroom you'll be doing around 30
push-ups each and every day which will
certainly lead to noticeable results in
a short amount of time now one of the
hardest parts of taking positive steps
towards your goals each day is getting
into the habit of taking those steps
each and every day you see small steps
can often especially be easy to brush
off or postpone since it may feel like
they're insignificant
however if you link these small steps to
tasks that you must do each day they
will become a part of your routine in
little time at all making it easy to
commit to making positive progress
towards your goals each and every day
so if there is a change that you'd like
to make in your life or a goal you want
to achieve I encourage you to think
about it as a journey of making small
shifts taking Tiny Steps what we now
refer to as microactions if you were to
shift just one degree closer to that
goal what would that look like what
small action could you take today then
another small action tomorrow at another
the day after that so I encourage you to
get clear on that action and commit to
start by taking it today and then share
what that action is in the comments I'd
love to read what you have to say so
thanks for watching remember you're the
only person who has the power to change
things in your life
you get your ass kicked along the way
things go sideways things go wrong
people let you down Partners don't work
out money falls out all these things
happen but I want you to reframe it in
your mind the success auditor success
tax auditor is looking looking and going
okay let's put another obstacle in front
of Wendy's way let's see if she can get
through that oh she saw the obstacle
turn around went back I don't think
she's going to be the one that reaches
her full potential but she could just
live life like everybody else and she'll
be okay let's see about liberio let's
see what's up liberio let's throw some
crap in front of him let's throw some
fears in front of him let's throw a
massive obstacle wow
he fought it he was a little sad it was
a little tough a little stressful a
couple sleepless nights but he's still
going okay check that box let's wait
about three months and throw some more
in his way and that's what I believe
success taxes I think we have to go
through the trials and tribulates we
have to build the grit we have to build
the wisdom
or else we don't deserve it I teach my
daughter she's killing it in softball I
said you win when no one else is
watching you have to pay your success
tax by practicing all the time when no
one's cheering no one's excited no one's
doing it over the summer she's down here
in my office pitching because she's
paying her success tax but guess what in
the fall when she plays she's gonna kill
it when she comes out and all her
friends will be like oh my God
everybody's admiring you you got the
game ball I wish I could do that you
wish you could do it pay success tax
if you're not willing to pay it get out
of the freaking game
don't think it says listen everybody
wants to be on stage in front of 50 000
people jamming and singing with
everybody going crazy in the crowd
singing their name but you know what
everybody's not willing to do is play in
their room until their fingers bleed to
pack up an old Chevy van and drive
around to Gig to Gig when two people
show up most people aren't willing to do
that everybody looks at the Beatles on
how amazing they were right do you know
the Beatles played like 10 000 different
uh time over over the years they played
almost every night like six nights a
week sometimes two gigs a night for
years and years and years never being
noticed sometimes one person in the
audience they paid their success tax and
then all of a sudden they were an
overnight sensation they weren't an
overnight sensation so think of it that
way frame it as success tax is part of
the journey and if you could say I'm not
saying you need to like the crap
I'm not saying you have to like the
journey not saying you have to like when
somebody screws you over the deal goes
sideways but what if you go wow if I get
through this I get another check box
from the success tax auditor you start
looking at life that way things change
and you realize you're here
because you're learning those skills to
get through them easier and quicker most
of the world most of the world sees a
wall and they turn around and go back
they're not deserving of the success you
are the type that will pound through it
get under it get around it climb over it
or blow it up with dynamite and that's
who wins the game so with that said
let's take it a step further
because I can talk about this until I'm
blue and like I could talk about this
every moment of every day when it comes
to my business because I've crushed it
in my business those fears that I had of
being a broke kid I didn't I didn't have
the right education I didn't go to
college I didn't have money I didn't
come from the right Town my parents both
worked to make you know probably 35
Grand combined separately and we always
stressed about money and I lived in a
bathroom with my dad I lived in a
trailer park with my mom until we got
evicted I mean crazy stuff right in
business I overcame all those fears I
failed miserably Winston Churchill said
the definition of success is going from
failure to failure without losing your
enthusiasm well I I did that before I
ever read that quote when I kept going I
paid my success tax I failed miserably
and I made it and in business I can make
those decisions I can I can fail
miserably I can lose millions of dollars
on a deal and I could be over in a day I
could I could have faith in someone I'm
working with and they let me down and it
hurts and I'm over in a day I can
rebound fast learn from it and go I have
trained my body I've trained my my my
insides I've trained my physiology I've
trained my words I've trained my
subconscious that we are freaking
Unstoppable nothing as a combined body
and unit nothing can stop us when you
have a goal in your head it's not even a
goal it's a fantasy it's a dream when
you have a book like this you can call
it your goal book and you write out your
goals and you go through I'm just about
to take you through bit by bit stage by
stage you go back to that but you can
look at it you can touch it you can just
make it real so remember if you do not
write out your goals as a plan and write
out how to accomplish them you don't
have a goal you have a wish you have a
dream you have a Daydream if you want to
go get a pen get a nice little book like
this you can do on your phone too you
can make a document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no
if you can make your goals real you
might as well make them huge big
enormous phenomenal so if you say well I
want more money that's my rug oh hang on
a minute hey I got ten dollars here
there you go you go well that's not my
goal but you said I want more money and
I learned this when I was to work with
women who were infertile that come and
go you know I just want to be pregnant I
want to be pregnant so bad if I was just
praying I go well as I look at your
notes you've been pregnant six times I
know I keep miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants explosive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal on whatever I'm going
to have my own company create my own
business invent something you can have a
relationship goal my relationship is
wonderful we grow in loving and respect
each other and you can have a health
goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many why's as you
kind of remember
you can come back any time to this and
think oh I thought of another why and
another why to leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
and I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich I long to be in a loving
relationship write it as if it's already
happening I am a millionaire I am in a
loving relation do you Michael that
doesn't make sense it does make sense
because your mind only works in the
present tense when you say next year
I'll have a bikini body it doesn't know
what next year is
and so you must write your rules in the
present tense I am I always I have I do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day are you going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in you see the best goal in
the world will not work if you don't
work and many people fail at this point
they write out a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and I think that's it it's not
it if you want to be madly in love right
are all the reasons why but then you
have got to put yourself in front of the
kind of person you want to share your
life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you so I want you to really
understand that the best goal will not
work if you don't work you can have the
start point
but you have to keep going many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success you wouldn't I don't think so
you know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12
years that's a long night 12 years and
people said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for KFC I said yeah but
it's not my goal and he stuck it out and
many people have got so close to success
and had to keep going and you have to
keep going so
look at your Diesel and decide you will
give more to your goal give even more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
everything we as human beings have
created
on this planet
but essentially fast created in our
minds
all that you see which is human work on
this planet first
[Music]
found expression in the mind then it got
manifested
in the outside world
[Music]
the wonderful things that we have done
on this planet
and the horrible things that we have
done on this planet both have come
so if you are concerned as to what we
create in this world it's extremely
important that first of all we learn to
create the right things in our mind how
we keep our minds
if we do not have the power to keep our
minds the way we want it
what we create in the world is also
going to be very accidental and
haphazard
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day a man took a walk he
went for a long walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate is indeed
just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt
a little tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was
very cushiony grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I am well
rested
but I'm feeling hungry I wish I had
something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him
you need to understand they have the
services like that
[Music]
don't ask questions
who came and he ate
stomach became full
then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
you are monkeys your tail fell away not
me Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as merkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's a
necessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is if
I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they're going to
surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghosts surrounded him
and started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghosts
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization
it in turn organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body
your mind your emotion and the
fundamental life energies are organized
in One Direction once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa raksha
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible levels of
comfort and convenience to us in the
last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life
simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they asked for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is her simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God he's the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive for what
you want
you about the neurophysiology of
forgiveness
sure
think about
Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits are hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no yes and that you
keep doing it enough times it's no
longer conscious that you're holding a
grudge
it's no longer conscious
that you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody is
that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person
that's the lens that we're perceiving
reality are you with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still
and so then the person says I'm not that
person and you say oh no I know I just
had this event in my past and I'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it it's just how do we
overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
your unfolding is nobody no one no thing
nowhere no time and the identity and the
personality is gone energy is going to
move Scott to it's going to follow the
path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion when you feel true true
kindness and care it's hard to hold the
grudge
are you with me still yes so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still yeah so then from
a Quantum perspective you are actually
as a creator of reality holding yourself
hostage because of that person
and you are holding them hostage because
of that experience and you have an
energetic Bond that's connecting you to
them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that energetic
agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change in your
emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken and once it's broken
now all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and this has happened
to me in my life that people show up 10
years later completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because they had transformed and
and I let them go
so then
forgiveness
from a Quantum perspective in a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
it's all it is and when you start
getting happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still now
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending in energy to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
to boost the brain are you with me still
so then once the Energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin and you
feel more love then you feel The Grudge
so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation and oxytocin
then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
matter to matter you can do it but it's
it takes a long time and a lot of work
and then you forgive and then you're
like I don't want to forgive him yet
halfway forgive them
and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
came to our event in
in Tacoma Washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
Oneness
and and that frequency had a message for
her and it said and she was an
incredible Bliss when this happened
I sent four Angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her tariffs
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the Divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy move right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for now she's
healed she's healthy she's happy and
she's on with a new life she's born
again my mother would love this she's
born again in the same life reborn in
the same way didn't pass to a birth
canal for it
she just was born again in the same life
she got a new lease in one instant that
energy was carrying a message and it
made its way all the way into the body
and the Bliss and the joy and the
Gratitude and the love that she felt
and the message that was carried would
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness
that's the Divine having its way with
you see this line
that's called The Terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it and on the other
side of the terror barrier is something
we call Freedom
and you know
very few people get through that Terror
barrier it's rather sad freedom is
available to everyone there isn't anyone
that cannot live the way they want to
live
see
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now I'm going to show you why people
experience buyer's remorse when they buy
something really want then they back
away or they go to move and they don't
they go to change jobs and they don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why
fear causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the X represents
the unknown Factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we had the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a mass of molecules and a
very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body is in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts that harmonize with
the vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting X-Type
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
Paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison and walk out into
Freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
X-Type conditioning X-Type vibration the
power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from Left
Field above boom in comes a y-type idea
what is the y-type idea the y-type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing
yet might be moved to another city
change jobs sell the house buy the farm
whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask the
guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea but as long as the why ideas just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen well that's
when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power Flows In
and what do they do they got the y-type
idea now for some for some strange
reason they know that they've got to get
emotionally involved that they're going
to act on that idea they don't
understand what's going to happen but
clearly understand this your central
nervous system is the most complex
electrical system in the universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling yet would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mine that's when
all hell breaks loose
because the body moves in to an extra XY
vibration it's not in the X vibration
not the one that we're comfortable with
may not like the results but we're
comfortable no on a conscious level
everything's going crazy on a conscious
level we experience doubt the doubt
turns into an emotion called fear and
that fear is expressed through the body
as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like at least they're
comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that Terror
barrier
see the terror barrier is going Beyond
where you're at going to a new level I'm
going to tell you something when I set a
goal
if if it doesn't scare and excite me at
the same time I know I'm going in the
wrong direction
now I also understand that my Paradigm
is going to try and get me to bounce
back to where I was it doesn't want me
to move ahead
I don't want to live there
ice lived there for the first 26 years
of my life and for the last 50 I've had
a phenomenal life and it just keeps
getting better and I want you to do the
same thing understand what I've just
said I'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the Y
idea that moved their body into a
different vibration on a conscious level
they're experiencing some crazy stuff
they start to doubt their ability when
they'll never be able to pay for it they
experience fear the fear expresses
itself as anxiety
and bang you bounce off that Terror
barrier and you're right back
oh I might not be earning much here but
I know what it is
I I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't you know what to do say I'm going
to get rid of all that I understand it's
there but I don't want any part of it
and I'm going to go crashing right
through that Terror barrier
now does that get rid of the X energy no
the X energy
is still there you see but at least
you're over into Freedom you made the
move you did it and if you continue to
feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that y idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know where you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier I'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say
so true
they cave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek I used to struggle a
lot with manifesting just the idea of it
I would watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying I
didn't I just didn't understand it what
was manifesting a lot of attractions
like what are they saying I don't
understand the words that are coming out
of your mouth and I would rewind them to
watch again it's like I don't get it I
don't understand I don't I don't
understand and it seemed weird silly not
good enough for me to just sit on the
couch and think about money coming into
your wallet or whatever it was that
you're trying to manifest you got to go
do something that in law of attraction
you know action is at the end of
Attraction like you got to go off and do
the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
color of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again it's too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car new house or business growth or you
speaking on stage or whatever your goals
are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with
and as soon as I came up with an idea I
was like oh you can't do that or I had
to have the perfect Plan before I would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that
you can never plan all the way out
there's no way you know if you wait till
you have the perfect plan by the time
you start actually executing the plan is
is dead it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you shortcut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust that it's already and then go
do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things
maybe I'm a skeptic I don't know but in
running those experiments I I proved to
myself that yeah great ideas do flow
through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it
so number one reticular activating
system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something that
I would tell other people you know like
oh yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because because it I haven't spoken at a
stadium that big but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
David but look I've got I've got a belly
here I've got a you know whatever I'm
I'm I am healthy I am healthy and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that I judged and
that I didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to activate the Law of Attraction
check the video right there next to me I
think you'll love it continue to believe
and I'll see you there 95 of who we are
is those unconscious programs so then
becoming conscious of your unconscious
self or how many times do we have to
forget and go unconscious